[Music]
[Music]
anyway um arkansas yeah i'm even looking
at this thing right now i moved to
arkansas for bitcoin nobody could
[ __ ] pay me to move to arkansas have
you ever been to arkansas before
no if there's anybody in arkansas you
know they're like you know razorback
where the [ __ ] that college is there
that
hell no yeah no hell no i've never been
go to the lake of the ozarks that's
basically all of arkansas okay and well
it's in missouri but the look of the
ozarks it's just like
it's just [ __ ]
[Music]
it's just
just a yeah yeah [ __ ] time
[ __ ] time like because of like just
people yeah it's just weird ass people
yeah
low like uh i hate to even use you know
but
white trash oh okay yeah you could say
yeah well you know people i'm thinking
about the viewer who may be who may be
white trash it's okay
all right well hey
you're white trash bro
i would be honored if someone was just
you know
in a trailer or in like some retired gas
station
that like survived an economic
apocalypse and like they just live in
the second story of it
um and if they're listening to this
podcast
i would be very honored by that what's
good yeah
yeah northwest arkansas arkansas is
offering 10k and bitcoin
and and bike
so you get a bicycle you get 10 000 in
crypto and a bicycle and a mongoose yeah
sweet man all pegs don't get four pegs
you only get two lucky no and it's a
it's like a [ __ ] 19-inch mongoose for
a ten-year-old well you get a bike
exactly you didn't say i supposed to
ride this yeah do whatever you want yeah
you can put an engine on it [ __ ] you're
gonna be funny the bike they offered
remember those old bicycles that looked
like uh that looked like choppers yeah i
think they were called stink
maybe called stingrays i'm not sure but
they had a fat back tire yeah and and it
was impossible to go uphill on yeah yeah
those things look sweet look up those
are still in circulation there's no way
there's no way in hell just some kid on
there's some dude on ebay who owns one
oh sure i thought you meant like oh no
we're still making them nah yeah no but
it'd be sick to get one of those and
just like strap a go-kart engine to it
and [ __ ] look at that dude oh yeah
my buddy had that i thought he was so
[ __ ] cool that was like around the
time like american choppers was big and
[ __ ] too
yeah
down there
yep
all that kind of stuff
[Laughter]
that's what a crazy like relocation
program i've always wondered with all
the
you know because it's open land and it's
easier for you know [ __ ] like google
fiber and stuff to show up there and
i've always wondered could these random
ass states i don't know like a hundred
years assuming this [ __ ] doesn't burn up
become like come like
actually the place where crazy like
high-tech
like
cities end up developing because it's
just like it's a clean slate versus
trying to like retrofit it into la or
somewhere else i think that you're gonna
find a lot of people who want the best
of both both both worlds of like being
out of a big city but still wanting to
be in that yeah tech environment thing
yeah so and i think that in especially
in the future i can see it like being
uncool
to be in like a big city or something
like i think that like i i always wonder
about that too like social norms and
stuff like what becomes the new hip
thing yeah and then also just like
simply do people literally just do
everything by themselves and like
companies become these
like tiny independent things worth
billions of dollars but it's just like
people that live in arkansas yeah
something crazy like that i mean or
disney will just own everything which is
probably more likely yeah oh i can't
wait in the future it's going to be the
box of amazon studios versus disney who
won the box office this week yeah it's
gonna be that probably i would imagine
grim dude it is it's [ __ ] i mean it's
horrible that also 824 i think was there
they might get bought out by disney i
think [ __ ] off dude i read an article
about that yeah i mean um i
not the same but i did read an article
about how
i want to say they were
discussing like um i want to say that
they put up they basically put out a
number that they were looking for to be
acquired yeah okay that might be what it
was then yeah but still it's like
you think that's disney money dude
that's just
that sucks man
oh oh apple bottom oh sold out okay that
makes sense then because yeah they did
the uh they did the
they did that uh movie with denzel
washington the macbeth movie mm-hmm and
that looked pretty good and and you know
what did you watch it okay i
i don't know
okay so this sale went through last year
so
oh no no
they explored sale how much do they sell
for three did it happen
does that say three billion you know
apple doesn't that actually doesn't
bother me too much
because um
they
look at this [ __ ]
three billion it makes no sense because
apple still tries to be creative like
alina's worked on a bunch of their
commercials like in the past and dude i
have to like hard disagree not not the
like uh mostly it's like have you seen
their live conference oh that you know
i'm not talking about that stuff helen
oh okay
like i've remembered like they're
let's talk about the macbook pro and
they like jump down a hole now back to
john
yeah i mean yeah and it's like they're
like standing in a giant like like empty
room and it's just like
connectivity is always what we've been
about and integration yeah that kind of
thing that's it
look up uh look up the rock siri
commercial this is like a crazy ass i
mean granted it's like a
it's a very like hollywood thing within
the context of like what advertising is
they definitely do try to be creative
they have like other
commercials that are definitely more
like cinematic and heartfelt and stuff
and you can just let the visual play
you don't need the dialogue but
basically this was like advertising like
siri and like
his
crazy ass schedule
um so this is siri
yeah and he's like talking about his oh
so it's still the rock but he's just
talking you're talking about how siri
manages his schedule yeah okay she like
she had to sign like a crazy ass nda but
she was telling me after it came out
that like the production to get all
these locations and stuff like in the
same place and how like they played this
out was [ __ ] wild and even the
creative development process was
really intense um do you think that um
like obviously there's
everybody who worked on this is
very technically impressive and like
they're all well done but do you think
that this like creative or is it just
throwing a lot of money at a thing that
you think will get
yeah because there's like there it's
just and when i think of creativity i
always think about like what are you
trying to say or like what are you
trying to convey and like there was that
commercial in the what was it the 80s
for apple where like the woman runs in
on january 24th apple computer will
introduce macintosh
and you'll see why 1984 won't be
like 1984.
and like that feels a bit more like
inspired or like abstract and like weird
and definitely which obviously like it
appeals to me in a way but like when i
see the rock in anything now i'm just
like it just feels like a company
throwing money at something because
they're like people people are going to
collect this yeah you know no i mean i
guess like
in terms of like art this wouldn't isn't
necessarily artistic but i thought it
was
it's ambitious for sure yeah and i guess
it's creative in that like to take a
dude with a brand that is so
or i guess you know to combined you
would think
him and apple would sync up perfectly
like oh yeah it's like a no-brainer but
what i do know about the
creative process is like he has very
strict requirements about how he can be
like sort of shown and whatever and so
i guess like
i would call it creative in that like
it's kind of [ __ ] wild that they were
able to like come up with a concept that
both these two entities who like
really care about how they're
put out in the world able to tap dance
around the exactly
you